so title is is there evidence that
walking groups have health benefits a
systematic review and meta-analysis by
hanson and jones
and so this was a meta-analysis on
um
on intervention studies
with adult walking groups outdoors so i
didn't know that this was such a robust
uh area of research
largely because like i don't know i i
tend to focus on
exercise physiology and and strength
stuff and not necessarily like public
health interventions but i think this is
pretty popular in research like in the
uk
where uh you know they just
get a bunch of adults and they're like
hey why don't you guys get together and
walk through the park for a little bit
and we'll see if that does anything good
uh so there were 42 studies that met the
inclusion criteria for this
meta-analysis uh and and like i said
they were all adult subjects and it was
outdoor walking groups you get together
with you know maybe half a dozen a dozen
people
and you just stroll through the park for
you know 30 minutes an hour and not a
particularly intense pace
and uh all of the studies
included in this meta-analysis lasted
for a year or less so they're relatively
short-term studies uh everything i'm
about to talk about you don't
necessarily need to do it for five years
to start seeing improvements uh so all
of the interventions lasted a year or
less
and they led to significant decreases in
systolic blood pressure diastolic blood
pressure resting heart rate body fat
percentage body mass index total
cholesterol
depression scores on a on a standard
like depression symptoms inventory uh
increased vo2 max increased six minute
walk distance and score on the sf 36
physical functioning inventory which is
basically just asking like kind of how
much you struggle with activities of
daily living stuff like that um
but yeah so uh
essentially they found that if you get
outside with your homies uh and
walk a little bit not even that much a
few times a week 30 minutes for an hour
within a year that can reduce
10 different risk factors for all calls
mortality which is uh
pretty striking i think
and like you mentioned
i
you can't necessarily attribute
the findings of this meta-analysis
solely to walking like there could be a
social component since it was all group
based might be influenced just by
getting folks outside a bit more
but the
the bulk of the intervention itself was
a walking intervention
um
so yeah all of which is to say
uh i
do think that the
population level associations we see
between walking and all-cause mortality
i do think it's far more than mere
association
there's a lot of evidence that walking
interventions modify known risk factors
of mortality specifically uh
cardiovascular disease mortality um
and
yeah like it's it's not just uh
i don't think it's a mere association